hello everyone i'm dr umar malik and
welcome to mad simplified
pumpkin seeds also known as papita are a
common yet unrecognized gem for humans
and these pumpkin seeds are the focus
for our attention today after eating a
pumpkin you get these hard white seeds
and after you remove the shell or if you
buy them directly from your supermarket
you'll see that these seeds are small
green flat and oval
pumpkin seeds may be small but they are
packed full of valuable nutrients
eating only a small amount of them can
provide you with a substantial quantity
of healthy fats magnesium and zinc
because of this pumpkin seeds have been
associated with several health benefits
these include improved heart health
prostate health and protection against
certain cancers
what's more these seeds can be easily
incorporated into your diet
so here are top 5 health benefits of
pumpkin seeds
number one pumpkin seeds are full of
nutrients and antioxidants
one ounce of shell-free pumpkin seeds
has roughly 151 calories mainly from fat
and proteins present in it in addition
one ounce of pumpkin seeds contains 1.7
grams of fiber
5 grams of carbohydrates 7 grams of
protein 13 grams of omega fatty acids
and considerable quantities of
micronutrients like vitamin k phosphorus
manganese magnesium iron zinc and copper
they also contain a lot of antioxidants
a decent amount of polyunsaturated fats
potassium vitamin b2 and folate pumpkin
seeds contain antioxidants like
carotenoids and vitamin e antioxidants
can reduce inflammation and therefore
protect your cells from harmful free
radical damage
this is why consuming foods rich in
antioxidants can help protect against
many diseases
second important benefit that pumpkin
seeds provide is that they help in
improving prostate and bladder health
pumpkin seeds can help to relieve the
symptoms of benign prostatic hyperplasia
also known as bph
a condition in which the prostate gland
enlarges causing the males to have
problems with urination
in a one year study in over 1400 men
with bph
results showed that pumpkin seeds
consumption reduced symptoms of bph
improved urination and eventually
improved the quality of life
further research suggests that taking
pumpkin seeds or their products as
supplements can help treat the symptoms
of an overactive bladder
this was studied in another research the
results showed that 10 grams of pumpkin
seed extract given daily improved the
urinary function in over 45 men and
women with overactive bladders
additionally pumpkin seeds are a rich
source of zinc
lower zinc levels in blood are
associated with reduced sperm quality
and an increased risk of infertility in
men
evidence from one study suggests that
pumpkin seeds rich in zinc may also
protect human sperms from stress
trauma and drug related damage
pumpkin seeds are also high in
antioxidants and other nutrients that
can contribute to healthy testosterone
levels and improved overall health
together all these factors may benefit
fertility levels and reproductive
function especially in men
number three pumpkin seeds are a rich
source of magnesium
magnesium is an essential micronutrient
magnesium has been shown to be an
important part of more than 600 chemical
reactions in our body for example
adequate levels of magnesium are
important for controlling blood pressure
reducing the risk of heart diseases
forming and maintaining healthy bones
and regulating blood sugar levels
however in the u.s alone more than 79
percent of adults have a magnesium
intake below the recommended daily
amount
pumpkin seeds are one of the best
natural sources of magnesium
animal studies have shown that pumpkin
seed oil may reduce high blood pressure
and high cholesterol levels
these two are an important risk factor
for heart diseases a 12 week study in 35
females found that pumpkin seed oil
supplements reduced blood pressure by
seven percent and increased good hdl
cholesterol levels by 16 percent
this is amazing news because for many it
eliminates the need for bothersome
medications and undue side effects
number four pumpkin seeds help to
control high blood sugar levels
animal studies have shown that regular
consumption of moderate amount of
pumpkin seeds can reduce blood sugar
levels this is especially important for
people with diabetes who struggle to
control their blood sugar levels
as i mentioned earlier regarding the
role of magnesium and also the
cholesterol lowering properties of
pumpkin seeds
these additional benefits greatly
improve the quality of life in old
diabetic patients
not only that regular consumption of
pumpkin seeds in apparently healthy
individuals has shown to greatly
decrease the risk of developing diabetes
in older ages
researchers observed over 127
000 people their research found that
diets rich in magnesium were associated
with a 33 percent lower risk of type 2
diabetes in men and a 34 lower risk in
women
number fifth and very important benefit
of pumpkin seeds is that it is a simple
and rich source of fiber
pumpkin seeds are a great source of
dietary fiber shelled seeds provide 1.1
grams of fiber in a single 1 ounce
serving
a diet high in fiber promotes good
digestive health it also improves
constipation and diarrhea in addition
high fiber diets have been associated
with a reduced risk of heart diseases
type 2 diabetes and obesity
additionally pumpkin seeds are easy to
incorporate into your diet there are
popular snack that can be eaten either
raw or roasted salted or unsalted you
can eat them on their own or you can add
them to smoothies greek yogurt and fruit
salads you can also incorporate them
into meals by sprinkling them into
salads soups and cereals
some people also use pumpkin seeds in
baking bread and cakes
well friends with this we come to the
end of this video if you are new to our
channel show some love by liking and
sharing this video
we are committed to uploading highly
informative and interesting content for
our med simplified community support us
on youtube by becoming a member or
through patreon till then take care and
see you in the next video